[Music]
what if I told you that two siblings
aged 11 and 9 jumped off of a roof in a
building because they thought they would
come back to life would you believe that
yeah
at that age 9 - what wait 11 at night
they thought who fourth grade earnest
sixth grade oh they thought they would
respawn like in a video game my uncle
told me that when he was in junior high
he was inspired by a Superman comic book
he put on a [ __ ] cape and jumped off
of the roof of his house and got [ __ ]
up in junior high junior that's like
you're [ __ ] dumb do that junior high
I would have known more be past four
years old as unexcused yeah give it like
seven I can't believe those stupid
[ __ ] warnings we have on everything
in the world that they don't have a
warning on Superman comics it says
please don't do this
Yeah right because in videogames when
you jump on something too high you die
and then you sort of it right so you
guys didn't bring up videogames that's
the reason they're saying that these
kids did that or they just stop it yeah
it's pretty dumb and they also don't
know how to have [ __ ] [ __ ] parents
who didn't tell them not to do this [ __ ]
are they alive oh you they are okay cool
so we can we can make it go in your
calling so it actually came true comes
out of the coma in words they're like
wait I respond a lot differently alright
the glitch the parents apparently you
bought them each a smartphone and that
they would spent up to eight hours a day
playing mobile games oh my god this wait
is this in Europe why are they say
mobile games why are they calling it a
mobile mobile games yeah do they call it
mobile phone games here phone games yeah
guys which home game yeah no this isn't
mobile how the gas-station mobile I see
gas efficient no but the mobile station
that's all right I thought oil oil space
in the brand Mobile's like what do we
call that long yeah no what did he call
it mobile no the way that you just were
doing it doesn't matter
I really give you just trying to get to
say mobile like a bajo you had just said
it anyway so these two children t-mobile
okay what about the things that kids
have like little baby sleigh mobile that
that's a mobile chandelier two children
they jumped off the family's 50-foot
tall residential building to see if they
would come back to life just like their
video game avatars oh so they ended up
breaking do it as a kid put yourself in
your kid body you're on top of a nine
though yeah I'm scared shitless for sure
yeah they're brave I don't I wouldn't
call it brave brave I could have been
half of their age it's over been like
that's a stupid word unless there's
water now that's different what we're
the 9/11 hijackers breathe very top wow
I don't know how to dodge those bullets
man you're the comedian here not me so
will they break okay hey bro they broke
numerous bones and they required several
surgical procedures good thing they
didn't have their growth spurt yet yeah
the bones are developing there's a
little bit well what if they start
spurting in the middle of healing Oh No
so you got screws in there and it's like
wait I remember those growing pains I
never got them don't touch me talking to
bigger girls patting you it's got to be
the worst thing ever that's kind of the
tips not that much taller I don't know
about that much you know you [ __ ]
like take your shoes off do it it's
comparing though that's all you really
cushiony shoes you both need to be
barefoot audience okay back to back Tim
stop stop
so you're not the kind of guy that does
the half being but you're actually like
a full half less but the earth is also a
curve but if you're standing on the
curve part of yesterday okay anyway back
to the story
let's also curves oh that's awesome like
a cashew all right so it's reported that
the brother said that his sister said
big brother let's see whether we'll come
back to life like in the game okay Alisa
came from the [ __ ] seven-year-old
that's all right better 911 like like
the hijackers hijackers to commemorate
holy [ __ ]
sign it came back to that damn okay back
to this it was 9/11 on a high tower Wow
okay so he says then she she and I tried
jumping off the building she was willing
at first then she was afraid I will be a
girl's idea right I told her to close
her eyes then I took her hand and went
first I don't remember what happened
after that
listen to his little sister yeah it was
a kind of girl yes but not the whole way
cuz she's [ __ ] she finally got some
sense I was like trying to back hours
she was trying to back out got scared
yeah so then he's like no now we're
committing in this family we commit we
[ __ ] do now okay so let's scare you
though you know what's sad is that
didn't get to remember the best part
which when you kind of fly oh yeah the
coolest part that's the coolest part
because with many dishes woke up black
yeah didn't did they do did he land into
do you do you say just the ground says
that 39 year old father recalled seeing
his young daughter with a huge gash on
her cheek and ides wide open staring
into nothingness after the hall so then
he grabbed her and went to the hospital
and then paramedics arrived for this
[Laughter]
he's like that they're coming to get you
[ __ ] you you can clearly tell who was
the [ __ ] favorite Wow maybe it's in
Europe and have really small cars well
maybe that deal and maybe landing behind
like a bush or something yeah no a bush
which plan 9/11 this isn't even the weed
episode the patreon hit yeah we're gonna
do a weed episode I'm in and I'm gonna
do the only hint Vegas Rock bomb grip in
the history of mankind
no he's gonna go for the Guinness World
Record to have like a big bomb we're
have to stand on a chair like this and
someone else's [ __ ] lighting the
lighter long story one damn room yeah
that was like five four and a half the
Guinness world record and we want to
have the Guinness official present yeah
to confirm the record is broken yeah
Dhabi wonderful then people who found
out about the story they were like what
old ass kids yeah I'm doing [ __ ]
come on so a lot of people online are
thinking that the parents push them off
what spenders own mouth I said push them
up and I spit all the way over yeah you
sure did
I'm sorry yeah I just thought fly your
guys's way we need a peck big glass here
yeah that's not covet safe no could even
pronounce the elf anyway she said Pepsi
and Spanish leave her alone I wasn't
gonna say 300 kicked them and then they
flew off I don't know like I don't know
what they're saying but the whole thing
here this is China
people blaming the parents in the
wanting money
paycheck or whatever that's what their
kind of thing Oh like like please go
find me and my children because no know
what that look okay so the family is
suing the video game company blaming
them for their children being this what
game by the way or not it was no no it
was you know flappy bird game and
mini-world maybe it's like a game out
there
yeah China [ __ ] I grew up on the [ __ ]
kung-fu movies were like the [ __ ]
final rooftop and [ __ ] I never thought I
could do it will you never allowed to be
on on the movies Park for eight hours a
day I was watching the 8 hours day Oh
were you my dad's house so my dad's home
instead we go get more yeah alright good
point
but I wouldn't like I would climb to the
top of the wall still and like look down
like no I love climbing trees rooftops
all that but I never was like I'm gonna
jump this [ __ ] and fly well I
would baby step it like start with small
I don't go straight to 50 feet you know
like if you tried even like 7 feet or
like 6 feet ok this kind of hurts yeah I
mean there is something screwy gon do
you think the parents kicked them off so
they could collect money well that's
what they're saying because of the fact
that they're suing the video game
company they're like there's some shady
[ __ ] here these kids are too old to
think things yeah
Elevens like 5th grade that's pretty
drastic like throwing your own kids off
of the building just to sue a company or
maybe it wasn't even the building maybe
like something else happen well you've
fallen from something like Bart said
you've fallen from something in your
life and felt pain and gone this hurts
you're not gonna show these photos of
what so push kids yeah I want to see
crush kids yeah and then this is the
building that should look like snowboard
boots holy [ __ ] are they gonna be able
to walk again I don't know oh I like how
they're looking down like you'll see
that that's where it happens the dad I
believe what the hell the dad like
should I try man
get more money yeah that is the dead
damn that's [ __ ] crazy you never just
looked down from buildings and go what
if I get dizzy oh I don't remember if I
asked this on on jakey knees or no but I
remember having this conversation
recently maybe with Casey but anyway if
you would decide to jump off a building
would you go face-first or go back
like what like purpose of killing myself
yeah it's bad but all face face first I
want to see what's happening it's like
it's either do you want to look at the
floor coming up to you or do you want to
just be surprised by the impact I also
don't want to see the [ __ ] me going
away from the world but that's in clouds
get a smile I want to see it but also I
want to like squirrel suits filed and
like flip around and do bad like [ __ ]
magic and like I want to feel that like
flight for like a one and a half second
looking at it yeah cuz I don't know I
feel like for me personally I think I
would go right back because like I could
feel like the wind like you know behind
me and like I could just look at the sky
and then I would like close her eyes I
feel like are you gonna look at where
you're landing first before you go back
or you just go [ __ ] it and this walk I
[Laughter]
do look first okay that looks yeah I'd
be [ __ ] up and inconsiderate if
they're like people down there in jet
yeah have you all seen that a Kiwi
animated digital short but the little
Kiwi bird oh so cute so uh if this this
Kiwi he's like there's there's a cliff
right and he is on like a little rope
and he's spending like a long last time
getting these like little trees and
hammering him to the side of the cliff
and then he finally looks down he's like
okay sweetie claps he's done he looks
over he puts on little [ __ ] like
flight goggles jumps off the cliff and
then he puts out his little tiny wings
that are too small so he feels like he's
flying for like a few seconds of his
life and then you hear a little he died
yeah he'll eat a suicidal bird fly I can
fly
I never was appointed so he's hammering
the trees to the side of the cliff so it
looks like he's flying over trees as
Oh Dark Star yeah and no no and oh it's
so sad I thought sure use the trees to
stop him as he's like going down the
side of the cliff like he smiles but
then you see like a little tear go down
his leg face that's a morbid cartoon
it's fun just like before a Pixar movie
yeah it sounds like a Pixar sure
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you